welcome to this video playing infernal
ex am pub a punk lot of 264 yellow so
above 2,600 this is some about his
rating here as well about 26 playing a
very classical fashion against this
opening here yeah this isn't this isn't
great really be five because of a 4mm
p.m. even even then they mediate a for
yeah he's the weekend his Queen side a
bit let's see
hmm
yeah I wonder if you can just play it in
a very direct fashion let's let's try
that it's a bit naive maybe but naive
firm or not if it wins the queenside
pancit sir it's interesting okay so i
was thinking d5 him hmm not sure that is
good maybe it maybe Jack a good idea
giving the the check IAM 97 i have e 5
this is probably probably not great for
him and after this i just dropped back
to the three
k well at some point he needs to take
let's see the night IAM the night is not
bad on them on the queenside so maybe
keep it simple
and now I need to make sure that this
Bishop is playing maybe p3 Bishop b2
yeah all the system very interesting
played this quickly garant giving him
some some counterclaim
now we have a position very typical of
the Banco he it seems that he didn't
really want to to defend it slowly this
position rather prefers to give a pawn
for some actively it's almost almost
certainly not not quite enough but it's
the typical practical compensation that
this type of pawn sacrifice often
involves let's see night night here
night c2f Knight b6 and night c4 again
not sure that this is so great
guy appears simply maybe I should take
let's take now think about that
how do I keep keep control one in this
position he's maybe attending see farm
okay let's set its control with that
maybe just wrote a 6cm bishop d to this
special takes be too
yeah I'm not turn not sure yeah I can
just you can just take it yeah I have no
way to to defend a form yeah yeah it's a
bit of a shame but I didn't find a good
solution it's pretty clear that
Whitehead had a very good position this
wasn't sufficient compensation but i
didn't i didn't see how to how to play
it correctly
yeah he's unfortunately pretty sure to
win on time therefore he doesn't really
need to find the best moves not sure
probably is still in excellent shape but
he had to had a much time morning much
better position before even check I
didn't see that one just a little trick
ok white rosanna this was it was
difficult to play maybe I'm not to
judging this right it's possible but I
don't really believe that this is enough
comp cannot cannot believe that I have
good control over see form and it's just
one move how idiotic is that after a
five it's basically gone it's very easy
I just might just um yeah a chest is so
simple sometimes and yet you don't tell
you don't play the you don't play the
simple a good news I just need to
prevent 9 p-6 of course if he does not
have an IP 6 this piece is just just bad
on bg7 and he cannot play it on this way
yeah my compass on almost + + 1.5 m and
this is because it's not just a pawn
it's also a good position this night is
so is so strong it cannot be driven away
at yes no play at all nothing this is
protected be to just one move kills at
all yeah but I'm just I'm just an idiot
I didn't I didn't
in this position well okay you want to
control you want to complete development
and Bishop g5 a text e7 so it's not
completely idiotic but a five is just
much much better after that like black
really has play he is getting rid of
this blockade and here i need to play
precisely i think what is still better
but it's it's a matter of precise play
now really precise play Bishop e3 is the
calm suggestion and rook a three Bishop
e3 rook a 3-2 have be three available
yeah this is already much much worse
compared to a 5 a-5 is really this is
almost winning like black has no play
whatsoever because he cannot ever ever
get rid of the c-4 night and this is
just just we cannot you don't have a PO
you don't have any palm break you can
never play this or this and white now
just builds up with no problem
whatsoever can move the bishop I would
be three or Bishop rook moves b3 just a
one-way street but after I didn't take
this chance he really punished me yeah
yeah I took I took ages but I didn't
find a moon rock a three is a relatively
best one yeah here whitey as in fact can
get a clear advantage again with taking
and Queen B 5 well I didn't really see
anything in this game he moves the rook
winning the piece so he needs to play
something like this and then Bishop e7
that's just good for what so I could
have gotten a big advantage again but it
didn't didn't see that one as well yeah
now I'm
was simply because of the bourne
weakness I mean he played a couple of
bad move so it wasn't wasn't so clear
cut but I didn't I mean no look at the
time you can play any kind of nonsense
and get away with it as they overstepped
the time Queenie 6 can't get good for
wide okay it's not relevant I cannot
finish the game in time the real point
of this game this is the situation where
I could have played a fine this is
something really to remember you need to
look at the opponent's resources what is
ideas and tiered is clearly not be 6 I
didn't really think in this position I
played this in four seconds and this is
a big mistake a5 is such a great move it
kills this light it secures the
important piece on c4 ended this is just
a winner and I just played Bishop g5 far
too quickly alright thanks for watching